My job,
right?
Right now,
I'm not partisan.
So whether Obama was delivering it or
not on leave to others or,
or my,
my private thoughts,
um,
any
buddy running for president and anybody
who serves as president has to do a
variety of the same thing,
which is to call up the very basic,
traditional American ideals and use them
to make an argument about our place in
the world and about public policy.
Uh,
certainly Obama has done that a lot and
very effectively in this campaign.
He places his campaign in this context
of American history and of American
ideals in our quest to live up to the
ideals in a way that all the greatest
presidential speeches have done from
Lincoln to Roosevelt to,
to Reagan.
Uh,
and that's what you've got to do.
And the John Mccain is not as proficient
a speaker from a prepared text.
He has written books and when he's in a
10 meeting,
he could talk the same way and make
people really understand how the moment
today,
uh,
meets,
meets the moments where the country has
been courageous in the past.
Yes.
For Mccain.
You know,
the challenge is going to be to step up
to him when he has to get the big formal
speech.